- Taylor, I got your email!
(door slams)
- Have a seat.
I don't know if you heard but uh,
someone stole my lunch today.
- That's horrible.
Who would do such a thing?
- Who would do such a thing.
I have witnesses that can put
you at the scene of the crime!
(suspenseful dramatic music)
Jason, you know you're getting
quite the reputation around here.
Do you remember Claudia's cupcakes
that went missing about three weeks ago?
- Yeah I remember.
- Oh you remember that.
How about all the cupcake wrappers
that showed up in your trash can?
- Someone gave them to me.
I didn't know that they were stolen.
- Right.
Where were you at 12:11 PM today?
- At my desk.
- And who might have
seen you at your desk?
- Uh Mike and uh--
- Okay.
Jason, Jason, Jason,
I don't have time for this, okay.
I'm about to get real hangry.
You don't wanna see me when I get hangry.
- I didn't do it!
- Take a look at these.
Do you know what these are?
- Oh my god.
- That's the contents of my lunch.
- Oh god.
- What's wrong, you look at little queasy.
- I can't look, I'm so full.
- Of all the food you stole!
Where's my lunch?
(loud bang)
- I don't know, I swear!
- Hey, sorry to bother you
but I think I accidentally
grabbed your bag.
- Ah no worries.
Yes girl, thank you.
- You're welcome.
(suspenseful dramatic music)
- Hey Jason, have you
seen my water bottle?
- I didn't take it!